ankunft in hannover 47 minderjährige
flüchtlinge aus griechischen lagern sind
nun in deutschland weitere sollen folgen
die situation in den lagern bleibt
bedrohlich auch wegen krone finanzhilfen
in der krise millionen deutsche müssen
in kurzarbeit gehen
arbeitsminister heil will für sie das
kurzarbeitergeld aufstocken
seit wochen kaum regen vor allem im
süden und osten kämpfen landwirte mit
den folgen der trockenheit die
waldbrandgefahr steigt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und willkommen
bei den 19 uhr nachrichten an diesem
samstag und wir beginnen mit einer
rettungsaktion für kinder und
jugendliche aus den völlig überfüllten
griechischen lagern dort auf den inseln
lesbos samos und kios ist die situation
ohnehin schon katastrophal dass corona
virus aber könnte die lage weiter
verschärfen
jetzt ist eine erste gruppe von 47
minderjährigen flüchtlingen in
deutschland eingetroffen
mehr als 4000 kinder und jugendliche
leben ohne ihre eltern in griechischen
flüchtlingslagern
deutschland und einige andere
europäische länder haben zugesagt 1600
von ihnen aufzunehmen
bereits am mittwoch waren zwölf
minderjährige in luxemburg angekommen
die bundesregierung will insgesamt
mindestens 350 unbegleitete kinder und
jugendliche nach deutschland holen
elisabeth schmidt berichtet 42 kinder
und fünf jugendliche landen am vormittag
in hannover unbegleitete minderjährige
deren eltern entweder auf der flucht
oder bereits in ihren herkunftsländern
gestorben sind afghanistan syrien und
eritrea
der weg nach europa ein politisches
tauziehen
ich hätte mir mehr gewünscht und vor
allen dingen auch schneller das ist
jetzt bis april gedacht hat ist
ärgerlich aber die hauptsache ist erst
einmal sind 47 immerhin in sicherheit
und darüber freue ich mich
die kinder stammen aus lagern auf den
griechischen inseln lesbos samos und
hieraus kein fließend wasser kaum
desinfektions möglichkeiten
menschenunwürdig in eine nicht
regierungs organisationen diese zustände
die kinder die am morgen in griechenland
gestartet sind sind die ersten von 350
die deutschland aus griechenland holen
will
reine symbolpolitik nennen das grüne und
linke im bundestag sie hatten geforderte
mehrere tausend schutzbedürftige
flüchtlinge auszufliegen
dass die bundesregierung hier so auf der
bremse steht kann ich mir nur damit
erklären dass ist ein kniefall vor der
rassistischen hetze der afd ist die afg
nennt die zustände in griechischen
lagern zwar auch katastrophal
flüchtlingskinder sollten aber nicht
nach deutschland so
dann in ihre herkunftsländer gebracht
werden sie sind alle in großfamilie den
groß gewordenen klaren strukturen ihrer
in ihrer heimat die für sie auch
lebenswichtig sind und in denen sie sich
wohl und sicher fühlen und dann muss man
gucken dass man genau diese situation
wieder herstellen kann
die bundesregierung sorgt sich dagegen
um einen drohenden corona virus ausbruch
in den überfüllten lagern und sieht sich
zu schnellem handeln verpflichtet
dies ist jetzt der erste schritt bei dem
deutschland wieder mal voran geht beim
nächsten schritt muss es dann aber so
sein dass auch die anderen in der
koalition der willigen also auch die
anderen europäischen partner dann
wirklich mitmachen
daumen hoch freude bei den 47 kindern
sie werden in den nächsten zwei wochen
im landkreis osnabrück medizinisch und
pädagogisch begleitet bevor sie dann in
deutschland verteilt werden
ja da fragt man sich schon warum bisher
nur so wenige kinder aus den
griechischen lagern herausgekommen sind
anne gellinek in brüssel
schließlich hatten sich doch immerhin
zehn eu staaten bereit erklärt die 1600
jungen flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
tatsächlich hatten deutschland und
luxemburg versucht eine koalition der
willigen zu schmieden aber das war vor
corona weil das virus grassiert haben
viele mitgliedstaaten nur zu gern die
krise als vorwand vorwand genommen und
keine weiteren flüchtlinge mehr
aufzunehmen und auch deutschland hat er
gebremst als die sache vorangetrieben
indem es kriterien aufgestellt hat die
fast nicht zu erfüllen sind man wolle so
hieß es im innenministerium
minderjährige unbegleitete flüchtlinge
aufnehmen unter 15 jahren und am
liebsten mädchen
fakt ist aber dass in den lagern auf den
griechischen inseln 90 prozent der
unbegleiteten minderjährigen männlich
sind und so kommt es zu der
niederschmetternd geringen zahl von
knapp 60 die heute in deutschland und
luxemburg der aufnahme gefunden haben
knapp 60 von 1.600 dann haben wir die
forderungen die lager ganz zu schließen
gleich gar keine chance oder ja dass die
lage auf den griechischen inseln
aufgelöst werden das ist sehr
unrealistisch und das hat zwei gründe
der erste ist dass es nach wie vor kein
europäisches asylsystem gibt also keine
quote nach der flüchtlinge aus dem
griechischen
ärgern auf alle eu mitgliedsstaaten
verteilt werden könnten
die eu-kommission will hier in den
nächsten wochen noch einmal einen
vorstoß wagen
und der zweite grund ist dass auch die
griechische regierung so paradox das
klingt kein interesse daran hat die
flüchtlinge von den inseln aufs festland
zu bringen
man fürchtet dass man dann die botschaft
senden könnte wer es auf die inseln
geschafft hat schafft es auch aufs
festland und vielleicht weiter nach
europa dass das noch mehr flüchtlinge in
boote zwingen könnte immerhin gibt es
eine positive nachricht in dieser woche
sollen rund 1000 menschen aus den lagern
in leer stehende wohnungen und hotels
umgesiedelt werden werden hauptsächlich
ältere menschen risikogruppen und
flüchtlinge mit vorerkrankungen damit
sie nicht vom virus infiziert werden
vielen dank an all jenen eck in brüssel
um auf die schlechte situation der
flüchtlinge auf den griechischen inseln
aufmerksam zu machen hat das bündnis
seebrücke in hamburg demonstriert mit
corona bedingtem sicherheitsabstand und
polizeilicher erlaubnis die teilnehmer
forderten eine evakuierung großer lager
in südeuropa auch in stuttgart wurde
demonstriert gegen die einschränkung der
grundrechte in der korona krise das
bundesverfassungsgericht hatte zuvor
einem eilantrag gegen das verbot der
demo stattgegeben
jeden tag jetzt der blick auf die
entwicklung der korona infektionszahlen
in deutschland stand 18 30 sind laut
johns hopkins universität 142 1325
infektionen durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten 85 1400 menschen als genesen 4403
starben in verbindung mit dem virus
dass deutschland bisher ohne massenhafte
arbeitslosigkeit durch die krise
gekommen ist liegt auch an unserem
system der kurzarbeit
dennoch sind wohl millionen von
beschäftigten betroffen die dadurch oft
nur noch über 60 prozent ihres
einkommens verfügen
während alle kosten weiter laufen
deshalb will arbeitsminister heil das
kurzarbeitergeld kurzfristig aufstocken
wie er heute sagte andreas ruppert
kurzarbeit ist in vielen branchen das
gebot der stunde
ein wirksames mittel um arbeitslosigkeit
zu verhindern allerdings sind für viele
arbeitnehmer die finanziellen einbußen
gravierend 60 prozent des nettolohns mit
kindern 67 so viel bleibt am monatsende
übrig viel zu wenig findet der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund fordert eine anhebung
des kurzarbeitergeldes auf mindestens 80
prozent
wir erleben gerade dass menschen die zu
100 prozent in kurzarbeit sind 40
prozent ihres einkommens verlieren das
macht für eine verkäuferin 6 bis 700
euro im monat aus für ein facharbeiter
industrie 850 bis 950 euro das halten
die menschen nicht durch eine anhebung
des kurzarbeitergeldes auf zeit diesem
vorschlag kann auch der
bundesarbeitsminister viel abgewinnen
wir müssen das gesetz dafür ändern wir
sind den laufenden gesprächen in der
bundesregierung und mit den
sozialpartnern dazu um einen weg zu
finden wie wir zu einer befristete
aufstockung des kurzarbeitergeldes
kommen können der vorschlag einer
befristeten aufstockung stößt beim
koalitionspartner auf wenig gegenliebe
es gibt keinen in der bundesregierung
oder der koalition abgesprochenen
vorschlag sondern es gibt gespräche des
bundesarbeitsministers mit den
sozialpartnern sprich gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeber wenden da gehört es auch hin
bis dato haben rund 725.000 betriebe
wegen der korona pandemie anträge auf
kurzarbeit gestellt die fdp sieht daher
keinen spielraum für eine anhebung die
rücklage könnte sonst zu schnell
schmelzen wenn das erhöht wird wichtig
ist erstmal dass möglichst viele
arbeitnehmer die es benötigen es auch
bekommen und das ist unser anliegen und
dass wir dann dafür sorgen auf möglichst
viele dieser arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
ab montag sollen vielerorts die
geschäfte unter auflagen wieder öffnen
erste vorsichtige schritte aus der krise
die schulen geschlossen unterricht nur
noch online nicht alle schülerinnen und
schüler kommen damit gut zurecht mehrere
bundesländer darunter bayern und hessen
reagieren jetzt und entscheiden keine
muss angst haben sitzen zu bleiben
begründung es sei nur eingeschränkt
möglich die leistungen zu bewähren
generell wolle man aber schüler und
eltern auf die möglichkeit hinweisen das
schuljahr freiwillig zu wiederholen
krank melden ohne persönlich zum arzt zu
müssen ein anruf genügt bisher galt
diese regel in corona zeiten zu groß war
das ansteckungsrisiko in hausarztpraxen
jetzt scheint die lage soweit unter
kontrolle dass die herkömmlichen
bestimmungen wieder in kraft treten
können ab montag muss sich jeder
arbeitnehmer mit atemwegserkrankungen
wieder untersuchen lassen und schon gibt
es streit
stefan lobenstein die hausärzte haben
umgestellt ihre praxen kroner sicher
gemacht ob das reicht wenn tatsächlich
ein patient mit einer unentdeckten
infektion kommen ist ansichtssache
der gemeinsame bundesausschuss der
krankenkassen und ärzte verweist auf
sinkende infektionszahlen die behelfs
regelung kann deshalb ohne gefahr einer
erhöhung des infektionsrisikos für
patientinnen und patienten oder
ärztinnen und ärzte zum vorgesehenen
termin auslaufen
die ärztevertreter die im ausschuss
überstimmt wurden sehen dass inmitten
der korona krise anders da muss man
wirklich nur hinterfragen macht das
gerade in dieser kürze der maßnahme
jetzt während einer noch nicht klaren
strategie sind so eine regelung
auszusetzen
kritik kommt auch aus der politik ich
halte die regelung für falsch und es hat
mich schon sehr überrascht das ist die
entscheidung so getroffen wurde von der
selbstverwaltung weil die
bundesregierung und auch die länder
entschieden haben das kontaktverbot bis
zum dritten mal aufrecht zu erhalten und
ich hätte erwartet dass die verlängerung
dieser regelung auch bis zum dritten mal
verlängert wird
offenbar arbeiten zurzeit viele
patienten ihren arzt aus angst sich
anzustecken
deshalb sind die wartezimmer leer viele
warnen wenn patienten sich nicht zum
arzt trauen könnten andere
gesundheitsgefahren übersehen werden es
bleibt eine zwickmühle zum arzt gehen
kann ein risiko sein nicht gehen aber
auch schauen wir in die usa das land das
die meisten cupid 19 opfer zu beklagen
hat hier zeigt präsident trump
sympathien für demonstranten die gegen
die ausgangssperren mobil machen
auch trump will ein schnelles ende der
beschränkungen um die wirtschaft wieder
anzukurbeln
die gouverneure vieler bundesstaaten
sehen das aber anders
die gefahren durch das virus sei noch
lange nicht gebannt
ines trams sie rufen den schlachthof
präsident tram und sie rufen nach ihrem
job und ihrem gewohnten alltag
demonstranten von michigan des
kalifornien
angestachelt von internetforen und
konservativen sender
die einschränkung des alltags nennen sie
tyrannei sie wollen uns beherrschen uns
vorschreiben wie wir für unsere
gesundheit sorgen dass recht haben sie
nicht wir müssen unsere bürgerrechte
zurückholen und unsere freiheiten die
grippe tötet mehr als corona aber da
wird nicht das gesamte land
runtergefahren der präsident heizt die
proteste an auf twitter ruft er zur
befreiung von michigan minnesota und für
guinea auf von demokraten geführte
starken mit strikten ausgangssperren
hatte schon zuvor für ein schrittweises
hochfahren des landes plädiert nun
unterstützung für die demonstranten
das sind menschen die ihre meinung
ausdrücken da scheinen sehr
verantwortungsvolle menschen zu sein die
man ein bisschen grob behandelt hat
entsetzt sind einige der gouverneure
denen trump s übertragen hat die
wirtschaft vorsichtig hochzufahren
ihnen fehlen tests nun zusätzlich druck
aus dem weißen haus
das ist ekelhaft verantwortungslos es
ist gefährlich bombastisch denn es regt
menschen an gefährliche dinge zu tun
es ist derzeit riskant sich zu
versammeln und die weisungen zu
missachten
derweil kehren einige staaten zum alltag
zurück die strände in florida sind seit
gestern wieder offen
trotz steigender infektionszahlen dort
in den nahen osten dort ist iran das
land das am stärksten von der pandemie
betroffen ist dennoch hat die regierung
heute in der hauptstadt teheran die
beschränkungen gelockert viele geschäfte
dürfen wieder öffnen
doch die menschen sind skeptisch
ist aus teheran zu hören sie bleiben
größtenteils aus angst vor dem virus zu
hause der übliche verkehrsstau blieb aus
die hauptstädter gehen offenbar auf
abstand auch in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln die prekäre lage in iran
auch für die nachbarländer ist das eine
gefährliche situation
beispiel afghanistan seit jahrzehnten
herrschen dort krieg und terror
das gesundheitssystem ist marode und
jeden tag hören jetzt viele afghanen aus
iran zurück in ihre heimat
jeder von ihnen könnte ein corona
überträger sein
katrin eigendorf berichtet am
grenzübergang islam karla kommen täglich
hunderte afghanische gastarbeiter an die
aus dem iran in ihr heimatland
zurückkehren müssen
wenn irgendjemand sich krank fühlt bitte
melden ihr bekommt kostenlose behandlung
rufen sie die befürchtung dass die
rückkehrer sich in iran oder auf der
reise infiziert haben ist groß die
iranische regierung steckt 40 bis 45
menschen zusammen in einen bus wenn sie
sie zurück schickt das ist gegen die
regeln der weltgesundheitsorganisation
wir sind sehr besorgt
afghanistans westgrenze ist zum
einfallstor für das corona virus
geworden
alleine im märz kamen über 150000
afghanen aus iran zurück die regierung
hat inzwischen ein ausgehverbot verhängt
die kontrollen wurden ausgeweitet
in kabul haben freiwillige sich
zusammengetan um straßen und geschäfte
zu desinfizieren
kaum ein land ist so schlecht auf die
krise vorbereitet wie afghanistan
das gesundheitssystem liegt am boden es
fehlt an allem
50 prozent der menschen leben unterhalb
der armutsgrenze
der hunger wird die menschen töten nicht
das virus wie du siehst sind alle
geschäfte und märkte geschlossen das
wird eine menge probleme verursachen
hinzu kommt die schlechte
sicherheitslage die eine effektive
bekämpfung der korona krise in
afghanistan weiterhin erschwert
wie die welt gegen das corona virus
kämpft nachzulesen bei uns online in der
zdf- heute- app alle entwicklungen der
pandemie in einem live blog darüber
hinaus berichte unserer korrespondenten
aus den corona krisenregionen in
hongkong hat die polizei mindestens 14
führende aktivisten der
demokratiebewegung festgenommen
der vorwurf sie hätten illegale
versammlungen in der chinesischen
sonderverwaltungszone organisiert
menschenrechtler kritisierten die
festnahmen als politisch motiviert seit
sommer vergangenen jahres gab es in
hongkong immer wieder massenproteste für
mehr demokratie
viele haben sich in den letzten tagen
über das gute wetter gefreut
kein gutes wetter war es für unsere
wälder und den boden
bislang zeigt sich der april extrem
trocken normalerweise fallen in diesem
monat im bundesdurchschnitt mehr als 50
liter regen pro quadratmeter bislang
waren es nur 1,5 liter die folge
dürre gefahr vor allem im süden und
osten deutschlands
was das heisst zeigt jan meyer am
beispiel brandenburg
trockenes laub raschelt auf trockenen
waldboden förster viele pause macht sich
sorgen nach drei wochen fast ohne regen
ist brandenburgs weit in gefahr
wir haben hier noch die vegetation die
vertrocknete aus dem letzten jahr
und dadurch dass noch keine andere
vegetation da ist ist dass dieses
vertrocknete auch so gefährlich für den
wald dadurch können schnell boden feuer
im wald ausbrechen
in der wahlzentrale wünsdorf gehen schon
jetzt jeden tag neue meldungen ein
mit sensoren wird der gesamte
brandenburger wald beobachtet in diesem
jahr gab es schon über 50 mal alarm
wir haben einmal die ausgangslage die
schon sehr schwierig ist zwei dürre
jahre 2018 und 2019 hinter uns und 20
zeichnet sich jetzt so ab als ob wir
schon wieder mit einer dürre anfangen in
keinem anderen bundesland brennt der
wald so oft bei jüterbog vernichtete im
vergangenen jahr ein einziges feuer eine
fläche fast so groß wie hamburg wenn in
diesem jahr weiter so wenig regen fällt
drohen auch der landwirtschaft große
verluste
bauer thomas goebel will hier gemüse und
getreide ernten doch der kg sandboden
ist schon wieder völlig ausgetrocknet
ist nicht nur so dass ist kein regen
fällt dazu kommt immer unwahrscheinlich
viel sonnenschein kräftiger sonnenschein
gepaart mit wind und das haben wir in
diesem jahr wieder und vereinigt noch
viel viel zeit wie die anderen jahre das
trockene frühjahr geht vorerst weiter
auch in der kommenden woche wird kaum
regen erwartet ob und wenn ja wo es
morgen vielleicht doch mal nass wird das
sagt uns gleich katja hornisse das war
es von uns im heute journal um viertel
vor elf bringt sie marietta slomka auf
den neuesten stand
ich danke ihnen für ihr interesse
wünsche noch einen angenehmen abend und
sagen tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren heute
trennte ein wolkenband den kühlen
nordosten mit nur elf rat vom sommer
warmen südwesten mit 26 grad und in
diesem wolkenband hier gab es doch etwas
regen das waren auch einzelne gewitter
unterwegs und sowohl diese regenschauer
wie auch die gewitter begleiten uns auch
durch die nacht jedenfalls zwischen dem
nordhessischen bergland und dem
bayerischen wald sowie am alpenrand
selten bildet sich etwas nebel und hier
im nordosten ist es zum teil klar da
wird es dann sehr kalt da sinken die
temperaturen bis minus 1 grad deutlich
milder bleibt es richtung südwesten am
mildesten wahrscheinlich hier im rhein
main gebiet bis zu zwölf grad und morgen
liegen dann die höchsttemperaturen auf
rügen niedriger als die nach
temperaturen im rhein main gebiet da
werden es nämlich nur elf grad dagegen
werden es 24 grad hier am oberrhein in
norddeutschland strahlt dazu die sonne
bei einem schon recht böigem ostwind im
süden sind ein paar mehr quellwolken
unterwegs regenschauer und gewitter
beschränken sich aber doch meist auf
niederbayern und oberbayern und in den
nächsten tagen geht es dann mit viel
sonnenschein weiter aber auch mit
gefährlichem ostwind denn der kann den
lockeren boden über das land treiben und
das führt zu sichtbehinderungen auch auf
autobahnen passen sie also auf schönes
wochenende